[Applause]
may not be the heaviest guy in the
league but alan still
with his full weight coming down on you
arms around the neck and throat
that's gonna put some pressure on some
joints joelle wincing there
grabbing his lower back
i hope he's okay
i think you speak for every sixers fan
on the planet let me say that allen
let's take a look at our
taco bell take
the first this guy joel embiid in his
last 25 games he's averaged a double
double in almost five dimes a contest as
well
just the second nba player
since 82 83 with those numbers
and the other guy
is a guard
again proving my point how unique
he and his game are
the offensive rebound oh
clear some space on the wall kids
a new poster is coming soon to your
local sam goody oh
fine what did you buy him need
i'm no doctor but i think his back's
okay
the question is
how are the cavs wow
look out look out he might not be done
that was a throw down because i don't
think his hands touched the rim he
literally threw that watch out watch out
he wants another
matisse get it back to him
tyrese
baseline
[Music]
got to take a look at that embiid
dunk again our dnc driving again
[Applause]
his hand never even touched the ring he
just